okay we were on I was on break the show
wasn't unbreak but but we collectively
were sort of on on a break pat had a
break and Max had a break know is on
break now anyway during that time we
received a ton of voicemails at our
voicemail number which is two one nine
two david p you can call that number
anytime and there is this guy who every
once in a while he leaves they're not
even really funny angry messages or
funny hate mails they are
extraordinarily aggressive and
disgusting and despicable and what I do
find humorous about them is that while
on the one hand this is someone who
clearly hates me and hates the show they
continue watching they continue watching
even though they say that they they do
it only on reruns which is like what
does that even mean anyway they've
coined two new hate terms apparently
about Pat and I in this voicemail take a
listen hey quick --less you and your
little girlfriend
both of these guns were joining us and
the unwary glance well he don't like me
in this country go back to Argentine or
wherever you came from
you're the speaking combi and you know
you people are to watch yourself
i watch it every so often in a rerun for
a laugh so take your conspiracies and
your molars egg noodles and whatever you
your call me and you're struck and stick
them up you know i'd say something i
screwed both your mothers that's how you
were warning conceived that's how you
were delivered yeah
two guesses I'll give you as to what was
bleep there you know the good news about
the terms Virgina z-- and mammal and
mammillary clans is that it's not going
to trigger D monetization on YouTube not
that medical terms should anyway right
but we all know sort of how that works
thank you to everybody who called and
left messages saying that they missed me
I am back to 192 david p you can you can
email in or leave a voicemail either
saying you're glad I'm back or that
you're upset that I'm back and I know
many people are very very very upset
that I am back in facts had a few
welcome back voicemails this morning to
that effect okay we were going to have a
absolutely fantastic bonus show today
Pat was going to be joining me back from
the studio in Boston it was going to be
tremendous and then right as we were
starting to tape today's show we had
what I would describe as a technical
implosion which resulted in the show
being produced on a technical level in a
different way I'm going to talk about
that on the bonus show I will talk about
what I've been up to and I will talk
about what's coming up for the David
Pakman show and we will save the great
stories for tomorrow's bonus show when
hopefully Pat will be back and our tech
situation will be all resolved so
tomorrow's bonus show I do want people
have been emailing me saying David we
know you have those shares of Tesla what
do you think about Elon Musk's antics
which are hurting the Tesla share price
we are going to talk about that tomorrow
also tomorrow I am going to talk about a
very interesting new study an MRI study
that looked at the influence of
mindfulness meditation and yet again it
appears that you know what it's a very
low-cost thing low cost in terms of time
cost and money cost is zero if you have
access to the Internet and can read a
couple of articles and it seems to have
significant health benefits so we'll
talk about that tomorrow and also
tomorrow do we now have the ability to
say with certainty that Mike Pence wrote
that anonymous New York Times op-ed
blasting Donald Trump there is one
particular word people are pointing to
that they say this proves that it was
pence who wrote it so tomorrow we will
talk about that on today's bonus show I
will explain to you maybe I'll even show
you what's going on here because it is
crazy what's going on around me as I as
I film today's show about the tech
disaster that we had today and I'll talk
a little bit about my vacation and
seeing producer Lewis as well which is
great to see and much much more
get access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at WWE and pac-man calm it is
very very quick and it is very very
cheap particularly if you use the coupon
code vote soon
18 I will see you on today's bonus show
or you will see me or hear me in mere
minutes